can I thank the Home Secretary for
advanced site of her statement and join
her in paying tribute to the victims and
survivors of this hideous crime many of
those victims and survivors have been
crucial to establishing the inquiry in
the first place and also have been
involved working hard to make sure that
voices are heard and their strength
should be recognized their calls to
action must be heeded
there is no more hideous crime than
child sexual exploitation and abuse a
crime that preys on vulnerability and
leaves scars that are felt for the rest
of a young person's life
and the independent inquiry set up by
the Home secretary's predecessor the
right honorable member for maidenhead
identified failings across a wide range
of institutional settings and including
local councils the Anglican and Catholic
churches organized groups and networks
and in each area action is needed to
make sure that that abuse is tackled
wherever it is found
can I welcome the government's
acceptance that there needs to be a
redress screen for victims and survivors
of horrific historic abuse
and can I ask her the timetable and what
the next steps will be on this as that
trauma can last a lifetime and is truly
devastating for those who experience it
can I also say to the Home Secretary the
rest of the statement is inadequate as a
government response to such a serious
and weighty Report
I'm glad she's accepted the need to act
on 19 out of 20 recommendations that is
not the same as accepting the
recommendations nor is it the same as
setting out what action she's actually
going to take for example the inquiry
said
that victims and survivors should
receive a guarantee of specialist
therapeutic support or her statement
says is we will elicit views on the
future of therapeutic support well we
know that therapeutic support is
inadequate and we know that there are
lots of views already that was the whole
point of the inquiry to gather those
views and that evidence and on many of
the recommendations there is little
detail
and all she has done is simply point to
what the government is doing already I
really hope that there is more in the
full report that she refers to but there
is far too little to give any confidence
in the statement that she has set out
today
on mandatory reporting for child sexual
abuse labor called for this at near a
decade ago
the government finally agreed to do it
in April but all she's done today is
open a call for evidence well there have
already been lots of calls for evidence
in fact the inquiry gathered lots of
evidence and a best she could have
launched her own call for evidence some
time ago why isn't the mandatory
reporting in the victims bill that's our
opportunity to make progress rapidly and
it is far too weak in her response on
online sexual child sexual abuse
she's referred to the bill we know that
is long delayed and watered down but
this is not just about the legislation
it's also about the action that is taken
since then we've had an inspectorate
report on online abuse that would
describe the police response to online
child sexual abuse and exploitation as
too often leaving vulnerable Children at
Risk with examples of police taking up
to 18 months to make an arrest after
becoming aware children were at risk of
abuse there was nothing on that in her
statement what action is she going to
take on policing new evidence too from
the internet watch Foundation finding
that the number of web pages containing
category a material has more than
doubled since 2020 just in the last few
years alone and again the response is
Holy and adequate on charging we know
that the charge rates have got worse and
worse every year approximately 500 000
children will be sexually abused only
one in five of those are likely to
report their abuse
but only 11
of the cases that are reported result in
a charge down from over 30 percent in
2015. it has got so much worse over the
last few years that means the
overwhelming majority of child sexual
abusers are facing no consequences
criminals are getting away with these
terrible terrible crimes it's even got
worse than the last time we discussed
this topic in the house in October as
well and on child protection and the dis
the the barring service again we have
warned about gaps in the disclosure and
barring system again there are still
problems there and only last year we had
unaccompanied Asylum seeking children
being placed in hotels without properly
trained
DBS staff what has she done since then
even to reform Child Protection in her
own Department children and teenagers
have paid the price of the country's
failure to tackle child sexual abuse use
and exploitation
the rare home secretary's predecessor
did rightly set up this inquiry but
there is a responsibility on every
single one of us and in particular on
the Home Secretary and on the government
to make sure that there is actually
action that takes place this is about
the victims and survivors but it is also
about future generations of children
whose safety and lives will be at risk
if we do not see action